[Música]
cuidado para não engravidar
que mulher nunca ouviu essa frase na
vida a gente cresce ouvindo que a gente
precisa se cuidar e se planejar muito
bem pra engravidar na hora certa
bom eu com uma boa taurina me planejei
muito em meu plano era começar a tentar
engravidar há exatamente dois anos
depois que eu casei
eu que sempre tive controle sobre os
meus planos que nunca tive nenhuma
questão relacionada à minha saúde e que
no auge dos meus 32 anos ainda
considerava que tinha um tempinho no meu
relógio biológico foram alguns anos que
entre a descoberta de uma doença
genética e uma conseqüente baixa reserva
ovariana um aborto e um tratamento de
fertilização em vitro que não deu certo
que eu passei por um processo muito
profundo porque pra quem cresce ouvindo
que é tão fácil engravidar assim eu me
sentia a única mulher da qualidade
naquelas condições que não era capaz de
engravidar
especialmente nessa fase dos 30 e poucos
anos que a gente vê todo mundo se
reproduzir ao mesmo tempo né
- eu eu me sentir culpada
eu me senti menos mulher e me sentir
inferior em vários aspectos
foram muitas sessões de terapia e todos
os tratamentos alternativos que vocês
podem imaginar
para tentar entender o que eu estava
sentindo e mais do que isso do porquê de
eu estar me sentindo assim a nossa
cultura ela olha para a fertilidade como
algo tão sagrado do feminino que a gente
nem cogita a possibilidade de ela não
existe
é pouco se fala sobre isso muitas poucas
pessoas dividem as suas experiências e
por isso quando a gente é confrontado
com ela ou no caso com a ausência dela
a gente simplesmente não sabe como lidar
foi exatamente assim que eu me sentia ao
longo daquele período
sozinha cheia de dúvidas e sem ninguém
com quem compartilhar para quem
perguntar
hoje tem um lugar para onde todo mundo
vai quando quer buscar respostas mas
quer manter essas buscas no seu privado
né que é o google e foi pra lá que eu
fui diversas vezes ao longo desse
período para tirar dúvidas como qual
nível de beta hcg que eu posso
considerar normal uma gravidez ou então
como saber exatamente o dia da minha
relação ou então tem uma clássica que é
possível da beta da falso negativo no
exame de farmácia
essa é uma clássica entre tantas outras
dúvidas que eu tive ao longo desse
período
a verdade é que eu nem me lembro quantas
foram as vezes que eu fui pra lá mas em
uma dessas vezes eu parei pra mim
questioná
peraí será que sou só eu que estou
realizando esses tipos de buscas e
fazendo essas perguntas
eu fui olhar para os dados e descobri um
dado bastante interessante
as buscas pelo termo como engravidar
praticamente dobraram nos últimos 15
anos e hoje elas representam
praticamente metade de uma das maiores
buscas no brasil que é como emagrecer
esse dado me fez refletir se tem tanta
gente passando exatamente todo que eu
estava passando naquele momento porque
eu estava me sentindo tão sozinha
a oms tem um estudo que diz que 15% da
população mundial hoje sofre de
infertilidade
isso representa mais ou menos um a cada
cinco casais que passam por isso
vocês provavelmente conhecem algum
desses casais que não têm a menor noção
de que eles estejam passando por isso
agora se isso é uma realidade porque a
gente não está falando sobre isso
quais são as outras buscas que as
mulheres estão fazendo e que a gente não
tá vendo
e por que essas buscas são invisíveis
tem paralela bastante interessante desse
tema com o outro que é relacionamentos
abusivos
a onu mulheres têm uma pesquisa que diz
que três a cada cinco mulheres vivem um
relacionamento abusivo aqui de novo
você provavelmente conhece alguma dessas
mulheres e aqui de novo
talvez você não faça idéia de que ela
esteja vivendo isso o problema de
relacionamentos abusivos aqui o que
define o que é um relacionamento abusivo
não é tão claro vamos pensar a gente
vive numa sociedade onde a gente se
refere à companheira de alguém como a
mulher de alguém
e aí será que nós e ela mesma não pode
se considerar de certa forma propriedade
dessa pessoa
então se o seu companheiro pergunta onde
ela vai que roupa ela usa quer saber o
batom que ela quer usar
será que não é normal e se um dia ele
perdeu um pouco o tom e foi um pouco
agressivo será que não é aceitável é a
prova de que a linha que a linha que
define o relacionamento relacionamento
abusivo não é tão clara é que as buscas
por esse termo como identificar um
relacionamento abusivo tem crescido de
forma expressiva
um fato interessante é que
relacionamentos abusivos passaram a ser
procurados no google só partir de 2015
que foi exatamente um ano em que
feminicídio entrou na legislação
brasileira
é claro que antes disso as mulheres
viviam relacionamentos não tão legais
isso só mostra que só foi a partir desse
momento que elas conseguirão nomear o
que elas estavam passando o assédio
sexual tem uma dinâmica bastante
parecida
muitas das mulheres que sofrem assédio
não chegam a fazer uma denúncia e tem
vários motivos que levam a isso
medo do agressor
culpa ceticismo em relação à justiça mas
muitas dessas mulheres elas simplesmente
não sabem que passaram e sofreram abuso
tem um artigo que eu li da revista época
que dizia que uma das principais
barreiras do combate contra este tipo de
violência é a tolerância social com esse
contra esse tipo de ato
esse artigo trazer o estudo do ipea que
dizia que era uma pesquisa com
brasileiros e dizia que 91% dos
brasileiros afirmavam que concordavam
com a frase de que o marido que bate em
mulher tem que ir pra cadeia mas 89 por
cento dessas mesmas pessoas também
concordava que briga de marido e mulher
tem que ser resolvido em casa a gente
precisa falar sobre isso mas para que a
gente possa falar antes a gente precisa
enxergar essas questões
movimentos como omitiu em hollywood e
uma recente pesquisa no mercado
publicitário de são paulo que é o lugar
de onde eu venho começaram a discutir
esses assuntos e começaram a dar nome
para comportamentos que antes eram
considerados até a parte da cultura
desses ambientes
e foi só a partir desse momento que a
gente começou a enxergar e que algumas
transformações começaram a acontecer
existe uma teoria de uma cientista alemã
é uma cientista política alemã e essa
teoria se chama espiral do silêncio
ela diz que numa sociedade aqueles
grupos que se identificam com uma como a
minoria elas tendem a resguardar suas
opiniões e isso gera uma espiral uma
tendência progressiva o silêncio uma vez
que ao não se expressar aquele indivíduo
acaba compactuando com a opinião da
maioria
nós mulheres a gente tem passado por
muitas evoluções e muitas transformações
nas últimas décadas mas a gente ainda
pode se considerar uma minoria não em
termos numéricos mas em termos de voz e
de represas
a atividade e por isso a teoria da
espiral do silêncio ela se aplica a
essas questões que eu citei hoje e
tantas outras questões que a gente vive
no nosso dia a dia e o que ela faz é
colocar todas elas num limbo invisível a
invisibilidade dessas questões
ela só faz com que conceitos que são
opressores
eles se fortaleçam conceitos ideia de
que por exemplo uma mulher que não é
fértil não é útil para a sociedade ou
para o seu casamento
a idéia de que uma mulher que vive um
relacionamento abusivo é fraca hoje que
uma mulher que sofreu algum tipo de
abuso provocou a gente vem passando por
um momento de empoderamento feminino e
isso é maravilhoso mas em alguns
momentos a gente tende a achar que a
gente precisa ser forte o tempo todo ea
gente deixa de falar sobre essas
questões mas tornar essas questões
visíveis pode fazer com que esses
conceitos que existem e nos oprimem sem
que a gente nem perceba eles possam aos
poucos e desconstruídas esse sentimento
de que a gente precisa ser forte o tempo
todo
ele dá uma falsa impressão pra gente e
às vezes a gente não enxerga uma outra
questão que a vulnerabilidade
eu pessoalmente eu acredito que a
vulnerabilidade que muita gente pode
achar que pode nos fragiliza ainda mais
ela também pode nos deixar mais forte
pode não eu acredito que ela nos deixa
mais forte porque quando eu falo sobre
uma vulnerabilidade minha eu deixo a
outra mulher mais forte e quando a outra
está mais forte eu também tô 20 de
setembro 2018 5 e 50 da manhã
esse foi o exato momento em que meu
filho ver o mundo e além de emocionar
eu gosto muito de falar sobre ele
dividir um pouco da minha experiência
a maternidade mas todas as vezes que eu
faço isso sem exceção eu conto que antes
eu tive muita dificuldade de engravidar
várias dessas vezes eu ouvi do outro
lado alguém também compartilhando a sua
história ea de certa forma eu tomei isso
como uma missão
compartilhar minha experiência e eu não
faço isso para me gabar aqui a minha
história teve um final feliz eu faço
isso para que outras mulheres não se
sintam sozinhos falar sobre essas
questões sobre as nossas histórias pode
ter um poder mágico de tornar buscas que
hoje são invisíveis visíveis e quem sabe
assim a gente começa aos poucos a não
ter mais dúvida e acreditar que a gente
não tá sozinho
vocês mulheres não estão sozinhos
obrigada por me ouvirem hoje
[Aplausos]